We're at a cabin
in Korea town ran.
What are we even talking about right now?
We've been talking about the frustration of viral video,
viral and valuable and this overlap right here.
How do you get,
how do you get like we're trying to find that.
Trying to get weird spot.
Our content is like,
it could be so much more valuable to you guys.
Watch
videos.
Stop wanting our crap.
You guys.
You know what I mean?
Crazy.
No.
You know,
making a living from filmmaking,
you have to understand the insane struggle of balancing business and art.
Well,
yeah,
see that's the thing is we're trying to,
how do you create something meaningful that hits the numbers,
brings in money and is artful.
The laws.
Some ideas are more about the numbers,
others more about the art,
the capacity,
but half a year ago we thought of an idea together that felt like it was the
perfect balance.
We're going to bring them in.
Don't bring him to come in like single file,
but there won't be like concern.
The idea was,
what if you got people with completely opposite belief systems together in a
single room to share an authentic,
meaningful space?
You're not a,
you're not a concern.
You're not a liberal.
We would name this series,
middle ground.
The idea was entertaining but meaningful,
marketable,
but artful,
mainstream,
but challenging.
We thought we had a winner on our hands.
I feel like it got better and better as we went on the last,
the last one was just like crazy
until we got to the editing stage.
Taylor.
Ian,
what have you been going through?
Well,
you see there's this edit that has proven,
yeah,
difficult.
Um,
because it could go a bazillion different ways.
Actually,
I should look at this red thing.
It's not all fun and games.
What we do every day,
there's a different level of commitment that comes into play when building a
company with everybody pulling their weight that inspires,
but nobody has more pressure than Jason,
our founder and CEO,
who's responsible for the cash flow to make this whole thing work.
All right,
Jason,
what are you doing right now?
What about the call at an investor?
Ooh,
maybe investing in jubilee.
We're trying to raise capital and we're trying to raise around $750,000 to grow
jubilee,
which sounds like a lot and it is a lot.
Hi,
is this Josh?
Hi Josh.
This is Jason from Juliette.
How are you?
What we're trying to do?
It's expensive.
It takes time.
It takes money and honestly at first this idea of like raising capital and
finding investors is really,
really scary and really difficult,
but I think over time I've realized that you know what?
We're trying to do something really important.
Yeah,
but at the end of the day,
we want to just tell stories that speak to human connection.
I believe that this is something that the world needs and wants right now,
especially now more than ever when the world is divided and people are
discouraged,
yet we're asking deep questions is about purpose and passion and how do I give
back?
We want to be that media company that represents all of that.
This is Jason from jubilee.
We have huge vision and were first to get there.
We need some incredible people to support us financially.
We've got a potential investor.
His name is Perry,
to talk about whether here in domestic jubilee,
90% of startups die in the first couple of years.
So to ask people to give us money while we're still a super young startup is a
really ballsy and petrifying thing to do without anything to prove ourselves.
How do you convince investors?
You'll be the next Google,
the next Disney,
Netflix or Amazon,
and if nobody comes on board,
what happens?
Yeah,
you can send them a place.
We would all lose our jobs and there'd be no more jubilee.
You look phenomenal.
All
right.
Tell me a little bit more about jubilee.
So jubilee,
we are,
we want to be the definitive media company for millennials that is positive and
aspirational.
I feel like more now than ever,
like the world is very divided and we need stories to bring us together at this
point.
For me,
it's not a question of whether we'll see,
see it or not.
It's a matter of do we want to be a $30 million company?
We've got $300 million company or like a $3 billion company.
Okay.
All right.
That's badly audacious.
I mostly,
I guess when you're going through that kind of thought process,
what makes you even say,
you know what,
I,
I'm happy with being a smaller version,
not myself.
You know?
That's a good question.
You know,
I don't,
I don't think I appreciate,
or like when I'm in the founders or investors or whoever will just blow smoke up
people's by it and just say like,
we're going to be that $7 billion company.
That being said,
I really believe that there's going to be a major player in this space.
If we get the capital that we need and we get the advisors that we need,
which is on me right now,
we're going to be that size because someone will be that size and of that,
why not us?
I also know how difficult it's going to be in or how much worked out well.
Yeah.
Cool.
I appreciate it.
Thanks.
Yeah.
When did you,
that was very interesting to witness.
Was it?
This is,
how do you think,
how do you think you did this?
I don't think actually it was my a game.
I think I was like a little bit on how to be honest because I was like thinking
in the back of my head,
like what should I be saying?
Like how should I articulate that?
And then some people are like,
I just don't get it.
And you really feel like,
oh crap.
Yeah.
Like you're making nothing.
I have a whole list of investors and like,
you know,
the list is like almost 50 people now and that means like at least 30 or 40 of
them have sat down and they kind of tangentially
anyway,
getting investors on board is one thing,
but obviously there are other hurdles too.
Like getting to edit,
just to write for this new web series that we poured our hearts time,
energy and a lot of money into that just wasn't working.
You're having a hard time like tying it together and creating that like full
arch,
right?
Yeah,
kind of.
I see.
Very confused.
Of course things become even more complicated when everybody disagrees about how
to go forward.
Um,
so I feel like you're more,
he just had a lot more notes on this draft than he did on the previous drafts.
And then at the end he said that he preferred the last draft and he would rather
revert.
Yeah.
It just felt like it lost a spun navy of it.
Like I know we have the hook,
but I,
I feel like the hook isn't going to,
we gave Taylor probably the opposite feedback.
I'm trying to think.
So you were getting a lot of feedback,
getting a lot of feedback and a lot of different views on like opposing views,
opposing views,
middle sound film.
Yes.
Just like the opposing views in this video.
All Nice parallel were doing.
Oh,
I don't even notice that.
Like doing that.
Oh,
I see.
good morning.
Another day.
Oh my,
I agree.
It was good.
It was good to let's go.
Okay.
Uh,
hello.
Y'all pulled up some magic.
Yeah.
Still you gotta wash.
This is so much better cause there's so much better.
Yeah.
It's like Lowe's better.
Oh,
holy crap.
Nice.
Great.
Yeah,
I think it definitely took a huge step forward.
right.
Yeah.
Just to turn the way back,
way,
way better.
That's some good news guys.
Um,
I just found out that Steve Chen is the founder of youtube is going to invest in
it
a
huge deal.
Yeah.
Rap.
Well,
so hopefully the money is,
I mean this is him saying yes it does.
All of this is Morgan.
Yeah.
Yes.
It's the magic of the retreat.
We're going to do
higher quality content.
Wouldn't have to bring on more people.
Um,
but people are getting in.
Yeah.
We had Steve Chen,
who is the founder of Youtube,
uh,
invest in jubilee media,
which is crazy if you think about it.
It's been a crazy ride and I really believe that this is just the beginning.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
I feel really lucky and really blessed.
Like who else gets to start a company,
um,
with some of their closest friends,
people that you love and also get to do things and make content that people are
really touched and inspired by.
It feels like a dream.
Um,
that's Kinda the gist of what's going on in my life.
Yeah.
Okay.